[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to this
uh
[Music]
and uh i'm kareem bakir the co-founder
and ceo of instadiv
and we're here together welcome to the
with nicolas lopez our head of chain
products
as well as the marching or biology
expert
and uh today we're going to be speaking
about uh deep chains so
i will share my screen and get going so
hopefully this should work
so let me try to do this now
here we go so you should be seeing my
presentation now
perfect can you see my presentation
actually
yes we can see your presentation going
perfect excellent so
today we're very happy to present to you
our new deep chain product which is an
ai-powered cloud-native protein design
platform and this product is very
exciting because you can do
incredible things with it including
interacting with
language models trained on billions of
amino acids
very quickly and with no machine
learning expertise
and i'll start first by explaining why
we're doing this i mean what's the state
of
protein design today first i mean
proteins
are the building blocks of life
they are used in many life processes and
maybe marcin our biology expert can tell
us a bit more about them
right thank you kareem so as crime said
proteins are effectively what drives
life they're the
thing that catalyzes reactions in your
body they are the thing that
transports the nutrients that's the
these are the things that react to
signal and help
that these are the signals as well they
maintain the
balance in your organisms should do
everything
everything else in your in your body
except of some nucleic acids
it's essentially inert it's the proteins
that really do things
and the beautiful thing about proteins
is that
they're composed only of 20 amino acids
they are linear strings of amino acids
and these amino acids then fold into a
one
in the compact structure and that
structure is determined only by the
amino acid sequence
so that's a very well defined
problem and the it is the amino acids in
the protein chain
that dictate pertains function however a
single
small change to the sequence of amino
acids can lead to a major difference in
the
function it could it's a make or break a
thing for a protein a a single mutation
could make
your protein bind much stronger or much
weaker
it could change the specificity now your
protein could
react to something else than you
directed before
and therefore it's a beautiful case
for for design to optimize the protein
function
uh if we need to so i guess the
next slide if we went to it shows the
scale of the problem
in if we look at the human proteome
about twenty thousand give or take uh
proteins in a in human body
but there's over 300 million variants
a tiny mutation tiny mutations that
change
a base per here a base per there they
some of them can
can result in changing the amino acids
encoded by by this base birth
and therefore affect the the interaction
and affect the function
there's over 100 000 possible
interactions in a human body
and a single perturbation affects a lot
of those
but humans are not the only against in
nature there's
over a quarter of a billion unique
proteins identified in nature and that
doesn't mean that
quarter of a billion proteins overall in
nature it's just
quarter of a billion of unique sequences
and that's just a
drop in the ocean if you pick a droplet
from the ocean actually
uh you'd see that this out of all the
organisms there
85 percent are entirely new to science
and that's
common for all the droppers in the ocean
you could pick which means that we
have barely scratched the surface here
and
we could do lots of really great things
if we could only comprehend proteins
on a large global scale and that's
something egyptian helps us to do
absolutely thank you martin and uh i i
think it's it's a very exciting time
because i mean
marching gave you a sense of the
complexity of
protein interactions and and processes
and i believe it's an extremely uh like
interesting time because we are seeing
breakthroughs at the intersection of
machine learning
and biology and in particular the fact
that
we have now tools to estimate
in certain cases like whether it's shape
or function
the structure of proteins based on
sequence alone
i want to mention here obviously the
amazing breakthrough
from our colleagues at the deepmind
which been recently
published alpha falls and deepmind has
shown
that machine learning and especially
like deep learning
processes uh using attention are
actually capable of extracting
very interesting and very rich 3d
structure
information solely on on sequence
and i do believe that this is a sign of
things to come because
we are seeing this in in many many uh
recent
research publications i want to mention
also this one
from rise and all from facebook ai
research
where uh clearly the case is made again
that you can actually understand uh
and learn very useful representations
based on
a sequence alone and basically amino
acid sequences
alone and that is extremely interesting
that means that
today we have the capability with
machine
learning models particularly
transformers built on attention
to extract and give to users give to
biologists
extremely valuable information very
quickly it's all about
bringing in things together and really
this is at the heart of
what deep chain does and so if we look
at like
why did we build deep shine what's the
focus behind it
it's really uh this notion that today
protein design
is very challenging it's computationally
expensive
uh finding uh the right design when
you're looking
from an in silico perspective meaning
that you are
running like simulations on computers
can literally burn
millions of cpu hours it still is a very
manual process that relies on
human experts should you design this
mutation
to find the right protein target or
another is still driven in many ways by
human expertise and manual processes
and or computational brute force and
this is where
deep chain actually changes the status
quo
deep chain is built on a fast and
scalable
ai it can get you results when it comes
to protein design
in days rather than a much longer time
periods
and importantly it learns from biology
and from first
principles this is the notion that if i
train
large language models like large
attention-based models
on all the sequences all the you know
proteins that are available today well
you can actually
learn and and you know have the ai learn
representations which are useful for
your given problem
and this is one of the you know central
the value propositions that we are
bringing with with deep chain
like productizing these capabilities
which today
are in the realm of some of the world's
best research teams
such as the ones i've just mentioned and
making it
easy and accessible to uh biologists
and to help them on their tasks so we're
going to actually
show you a use case and maybe merchant
can tell us a bit more about this
particular one born morphogenetic
protein 2 that we have selected for this
presentation
yes thank you karim so bmp2
is a really fun protein it's a growth
factor
that well that's
advised to a receptor in your bone self
ante plays a crucial role in the in the
bone growth
so it essentially makes your bones your
cartilages
grow and regenerate therefore it's a
it's a very attractive clinical
clinically approved drug
to treat injuries especially spinal
fractures uh
it's been it's been a real wonder but it
comes with
a lot of adverse effects it can cause
ectopic growth
you can get too much bone growing
somewhere it can
it is a it's a signaling molecule so it
can cause a upside effect it can
activate things it shouldn't activate uh
an interesting thing is the same
molecule activates your white fat cells
so it and well we don't even know what
more
so if we now could improve the binding
of of this
protein so it's a native receptor to the
receptor in the
bare bone itself and and make it more
specific perhaps
by a bit more um tighter
we could improve the clinical efficacy
of such a drug
we could make the we could reduce the
amount of side effects we could make the
and
the um the patients healthier in a much
shorter
time period um i think that
well i know that because we'll show us
uh how it happens in the deep chain
absolutely so actually i'm going to stop
sharing and
leave it for nicolas to show us this
life here
you're on mute yeah
yeah thank you very much karim thank you
very much marcin for
um your introduction and
as martin said on the last bullet point
a very and a use for deep chain
would be to improve binding between a
binder and a receptor in the case of
the example presented by margin
the protein it's uh the binder the
growth
protein is the binder and the receptor
is a sun receptor
in a human cell surface
and what are we going to do with deep
you can make your screen uh full full
scale if possible
yeah can you see it here
is it better yes no it is better
yeah perfect okay um so what
a typical workflow on deep chain as
karim explains
consists on three different stages
the first stage will be to analyze
the sequence of the protein itself
which we are showing here we can see
that
in the structure there are four
different chains
two chains represent the protein and two
smaller chains
represents a d receptor and what we are
intending to design is the protein
in particular we are trying to mutate
residues in the protein
that will optimize the binder with the
receptor
as i said we can display in deep chain
the four different chains
as a sequence here and we can
actually interact with the selection and
see
how we like some sequences in this case
on the receptor
but we could uh shift into the
actual uh protein as you see here and
perform a selection
interact zoom in and we have a full 3d
display of the protein this is based in
state-of-the-art technology
powered by opengl webgl and
it's based on one of the most important
pro
projects on protein this aim on protein
and
displaying at the moment called mostar
and the first thing we are gonna do is
we are gonna
have a look at all these three sequences
when we upload a file into deep chain
we automatically have this
analysis of each for each position in
the sequence
which is the probability for each amino
acid
here we see the chain a which is the
actual
growth of protein and we see per
position
for example at the beginning that m
has a 30 of a probability maybe marching
can comment on why this is
yeah so thank you nicholas well the
the model that we're using here uh
that's
is not a model that's based on search on
any sort of a
sequence database it's a model that
understands proteins
as a whole and therefore it assumes that
the first
letter of the sequence should be a
methionine
and it says that okay apparently there
isn't that much of a bias here
but if i were to guess i would think
that methionine is a bit more
uh more likely than anything else what
we see in the
in this heat map is that there are
there's a lot of positions in which
most of the letters are blue deep blue
which means that
they're not preferred at all and just
one position is red which is the most
preferred
native uh native letter native amino
acid
however we see some positions that are
slightly more variable
which are yellow and blue and crucially
is that a that what we see is not
really just single side frequencies it's
not
something that you could derive from a
search on a database but rather
conditional probabilities
of these of this position of adopting
particular amino acid
given the rest of the sequence and while
it matters less here it matters a lot
when you
analyze same effects of multiple
mutations on the
on the protein so thank you martin
to recap we trained we pre-trained
transformer models
language models in billions of protein
sequences
so we train this system where
the ai knows what's the language of
proteins
we send the sequence available from the
structure from the pdb file
and we see what the transformer thinks
are the probabilities per position
of course the positions that are of
larger probability will be
the native amino acid right the wild
type
type we can show this particularly
with a bar plot in the bar plot we
exclude
the negative probability and we see that
there are zones
where the negative probability is quite
large and
the probabilities of mutations are quite
low
maybe marching can comment a bit on what
are these regions
yes so uh the the positions that we've
seen with very high
stacked bars what positions on the
surface of the proteins
are actually on the surface of the
complex really and
as such those were the slightly more
neutral positions um
but the lowest uh lowest bars are still
on the surface of the
of the protein but these are the put uh
the the
positions in the interface these are the
positions that are crucial
uh for the protein to either form the uh
the dimer that it does a in in the
living organism
or uh to bind to its receptor so
we see that for example positions 45
to actually 48 to uh to 57
are really really low and these are this
is that's the region where there is a
relatively flexible loop with a bit of a
alpha helix
that actually binds to the receptor and
it's the one of the most crucial
parts of the segments of the protein for
its
specificity and function great margin so
you are saying that positions with a low
probability of
mutation are positions of high function
in the protein
so they are very likely to interact with
other proteins around
and hence is filtering by this
probability
would be a very good way of interact
deciding where to perform these
mutations
and yes however all right
please please go ahead however one thing
that
we cannot mutate these at at will
we have to do a very informed mutations
because
these are the positions that are
important for the protein so uh on
contrary to
high chimney stack positions where we
can mutate and it doesn't really affect
the protein as such
here no no single mutation
is going to evolutionary or functionally
favorable
you have to look at them in tandem and
that's why it's
quite quite difficult to to do that
just by random sampling excellent martin
thank you
however we have a pdb file right so we
have a 3d structure of this sequence
so wouldn't it be cool to take the
sequence
and display it on top of the structure
to see how it looks
well you are all sorted because deep
chain can do that for you
you simply click on the playground on
the structure tab
and you will have exactly the same
distribution but now
you see how the probabilities distribute
in the actual chain
and you can change any chain on the pdb
file and see
exactly what is the distribution what is
more
how can we filter and just keep the
for example positions with very low
probability of mutations
well it's as simple as sliding the the
bar and deep chain will do that
filtering for you
so how easy is to interact with language
models on a 3d structure on deep chain
we have even options like showing the
actual
mutations or not which in this case of a
bar plot
they will not appear because as i said
we don't display it and we can also have
filters on
what is the initial and a target amino
acid that we would like to display and
this will also
add us filters so there is a lot of
functionality in the language models
i'll let you to you to explore and maybe
kareem can tell us why we did
make this available for a free
for a free user on deep chain
absolutely yeah actually there is a
question from the audience which is uh
more more details about
the or value proposition with with ai
and uh and and i hope like when you when
you see
uh you know like what you've just been
said by nicolas and martin that
the value proposition is quite clear no
one has
managed yet to build in one
product the capability to quickly
interrogate
a given a protein sequence visualize
you know what uh ai language models tell
you
and visualize it even in 3d like where
are the positions of interest and other
literally nobody has done that
and we're actually very proud of the
fact that we are actually opening up
deep chain
uh you know including like a totally
free version
so any student any biology student or
bioinformatics students in the world can
actually
interrogate and interact with our
powerful
you know ai models like built on
attention based uh
transformers and and this is i believe
uh very exciting we're very attached at
instead deep on making sure that
uh our products are available uh at
least in one format
for free and at the same time offer a
great value for professional users
thank you karim as a bonus on the
playground itself
we have a small language model based
protein designer so how does this work
well we just select a few positions that
we would like
to mutate here numbers
position number 27 34 39 and 46 and
based on this
probability matrix essentially the
probability per amino acid on each
position
we can just generate the most probable
sequence
using some markov chain
approach and here deep chain will
um show what is the most probable
sequence given those positions
as uh decided by the language model this
is an extra feature
that is very useful for a quick analysis
of a probable mutations another good
thing that we have is that by double
clicking one of the sequence
we can also input a sequence on the
playground
any sequence we want for example i will
add a few more sequence here
even though if a few more amino acids
here even though it doesn't
really make a lot of sense or or maybe
uh
sorry maybe delete some and
submit that sequence and we are expected
to
get these results in seconds
let's wait a bit so what happened here
is that our transformer model on the
server has done
inference and came back with the results
for that a given sequence
feel free to play with language models
just
sign into deep chain dot bio and you
will have
free uh trials with language models
up to five per day
and anything else you would like to uh
either here karim or martin
yes so i have something to add you say
you appended some secret
some letters at the end of the sequence
right right here or
yes it's what we've seen is that
the the model has
detected on its own and that the
additions that the
nikolas has done do not really make
sense in a context of biologic
as such we see that the the heat map got
a bit more diffused and the positions
that he has modified
uh essentially had a flat probability
distribution because
the bullet said no these are not what i
expect
and that's also something that a
biologist can can use
to assess at the effects of mutation for
example
if you see that there's a uh if you
observe a mutation
in a while in somewhere in in
in your experiment you could see if that
mutation is likely to be accepted
evolutionary
if you see a mutation in your in a
bacterium maybe it's a
antibiotic resistance granting one and
then
it should be a favorable evolutionary
and
you the model should accept it if it's a
mis-sense mutation that makes the
organism
lesser fit you'll see that your
probabilities will get
flatter more diffuse and the model will
believe it's um
it's poorer so that's all that drop in a
tool
to assess what your mutation really does
to the organism
very interesting inside margin there is
a lot more to show so i propose that we
move to the second column of the chain
which is the ai designer
martin would you like to tell us a bit
more about it yes so
i said our goal here with the bone
margin protein too was to optimize
binding
and what we wanted to do is we want to
do
is say we want to find such set of
mutations
that maximizes the binding given the
structure
however we want to want this mutations
to be
relatively minimal because we don't want
the uh designed protein
to have an off target at face to have uh
to have a
problem with folding and deep chain can
help us achieve that it's able to uh
through the ai
models behind the scenes it's able to
find
such a set of several mutations even
given
relatively large interface that they
result in a stable well-binding complex
and nicolas can show us how to do that
great so applying ai directed
mutagenesis
in a deep chain is as simple as
selecting some of the residues i
would like to mutate
and you will see them display here
and then will be as simple as clicking
on run experiment
however here i'm on the free version i
can switch to a pro version to show how
it works the free version
does not allow to run the experiment
but you will be able to just select some
of the experiments
some of the residues and
wait for 24 hours until deep chain
will start mutating those residues until
it finds a much better binder
if you can in a possible local
maximum of binding energy in that
sequence space so it is a minimization
of the actual energy of the protein
and it's also a maximum of the
binding on the protein and martin would
you like to
uh comment a bit more about the style
yes yes and i have also a comment on the
ai directed intelligences in both cases
of the ai that intelligence and decided
genesis and what we do is where we
we do quite an involved optimization and
it's not
only a local optimization so it's not
just that we repack the side chains and
see if it if they fit uh we all have
here were
dictionaries simulation based so it
really looks at the
at the protein complex as a whole which
differs it
uh differentiates it from a lot of other
solutions that
may try to achieve similar approach
and they will decide that without
genesis we can
achieve this a similar effect as we did
with the language models
so we get to see what effect a
particular
mutation would have or a set of
mutations would have on there on our
complex
uh using the same involved
optimization algorithms that power
airflow
you can see a with quite high uh
precision rate how how good or how bad
a particular mutation is for the for our
complex
and that allows us to once again verify
the
observed polymorphisms computationally
now not in terms of language models
but in terms of biophysics thank you
martin
here i quickly swapped why marching was
talking to a pro version
where i'm allowed to apply the directed
music genesis
and i will run an experiment by just
selecting the number maximum number of
mutations i would like
to get out of deep chain for example i
could select
50 positions and i would like only three
of those positions to actually
mutate among those 50 residues and also
how much you will like to
use of compute hours in your designs
something between
12 and 24 hours it could be optimal
depending on your structure
it's as simple as that and i just do the
run
you will see it launch it here and after
24 hours you will get an email
to your inbox saying your results are
ready
so let's go back to our demo project
which is available
for every user and check out some of
those results from deep chain
just a point and nikola it's actually on
the enterprise version that you will
have this
functionality and this will be released
pretty soon
but it's very cool and we wanted to give
you a first peek into it today
very good point kareem thanks
and martin would you like to comment a
bit about what
this scatter plot here is yes so
deep training is based on as i said on
simulations
and as such we're trying to optimize the
binding energy
and what we see here is in yellow is the
binding energy
as computed for the input structure
however well [ __ ] has internal
quality criteria so we try to make the
the infrastructure as good as possible
we sort of do a lot more to do a lot of
uh sampling to find the local energy
minima that can
adopt and these are the ones in uh in
green
and then a deep chain tries to optimize
the sequence
and these are the blue dots and what we
see is that
even with a relatively small run diction
was able to find
such designs that result not only in a
better
binding energy as such it so the dots
are further to the left
but also in the designs that have a
better
um relative binding energy uh which
means that
they are binding faster and binding
more more aptly
and all of these designs can be
interrogated by either clicking on the
point on the on the graph or
clicking on the on the design in the
list
and then all the tools in deep chain can
be applied
great it seems that deep chain has found
a design where
the mutated residues are quite happy at
least in terms of
gives a delta g's gives a delta
free energy on so that's
great but how can we cross validate
these results and say
hmm i wonder how would this look like
uh in a molecular dynamics um
simulation well deep chain is gets
uh you are sorted with deep chain
because by just going to the molecular
dynamics simulation
you can for any result found on deep
chain
run that simulation and again
after six or eight hours you need to
decide define the time steps
and some initial conditions and boundary
conditions
you will get the molecular dynamics
simulation
with a plot of the kinetic energy of the
structure as a function of time
here we get one of these molecular
dynamic simulations
this is running gromacs on the back end
and getting back the results and
downloading the trajectories for you
so you can visualize them here we see
how it looks this is not a video this is
an actual
like 3d uh plot that we can
rotate and zoom in zoom out and even
change
the appearance and for example we could
um change the the the actual aspect
of it by for example looking at the side
chains
if i uh for example click on some of the
configurations you will see that
i can change this cartoon representation
for something like more fun like for
example ball and stick
and of course in my small laptop it
might take a bit of time to render
but you can definitely play this as a
bonus stick simulation
and you see the actual behavior of this
molecular dynamics run marching maybe
you can comment a bit on
what is happening yes so at the
the microdynamics runs that edition
performs
are by necessity not uh not very long
it's not the tool to perform months of
uh md however it's a way to
run the md simulation in a consistent uh
well-designed
way it's able to it hey it's
it's able to tell you if your complex is
stable
it is able to tell you what are the
conformational effects
of a of your mutation and it allows you
to tell a to see
if the interactions you have observed in
the native structure are still present
there
uh if and most importantly you could see
how
how does the energy profile of the uh of
your system develop
we have a lot of reporting tools
available
in deep chain that allows you that allow
you to see
what really happens assimilated but
still
a realistic physical environment would
be a complex
so in here what we see is that the
compass is a
quite stable uh we see that the that's
i believe the total energy of the of the
complex
is gradually decreasing which
well it's in the cost of 15 nanoseconds
uh
which is already a good indication that
the design is
sensible not only from the point of view
of our target functions but also from
the point of view of physics
and that's um
yeah that's um we believe that's a
it's going to be quite useful for any
one of us
absolutely and and for me like the key
thing is that you have
in one platform the ability to uh
explore or with uh you know like
evaluate with
language models different uh like
mutations that you're interested in
but then have the fully autonomous
system
figure out new mutations of interest
that minimize
uh certain target energy profiles and
finally with md simulation that
nikolai displaying here you can actually
have
one first form of in-silico validation
of uh the particular sequence that you
have designed
because literally these are you know
simulations as much and
described which are very accurate and
gives you a sense
of what is happening to those micro
molecules so
having everything together basically uh
accelerates significantly
uh the process uh like the design
process
of a biologist and this is something
that
we're quite excited about so uh thanks a
lot for
the presentation uh nicola and uh maybe
i can
quickly revert to uh to uh the
presentation that we had
just share my screen again and so uh to
summarize we
just saw the live demo of of the product
we
we had the playground where we could
essentially interact
interact with uh language models
which have learned all uh you know
biology basically on all available
protein
sequences we're talking about hundreds
of millions of proteins here if not if
not more in certain cases
and the ai designer which we gave you
sort of like a preview it's not
available
uh yet but will be available soon is
this idea that you can
fully autonomously uh design uh new
sequences
uh for the like given energy
minimization
target that you are interested in and
finally molecular dynamics as we've seen
so if we were to summarize what's the
value added of of deep chain
really it is the fact that you are
having very powerful tools to move much
faster
into designing the protein target you're
interested in
we're talking about up to an order of
magnitude faster
and you can in certain cases have
actionable results in
24 hours or less with a fully autonomous
decision-making ai system so that is
quite exciting not only can you test
your
given mutations once that you have a
prior and believe are interesting
but the system can essentially
manufacture new
new sequences new mutations on its own
and finally as we discussed you can
validate this with
complex molecular dynamic simulations
now the best part of all this is it's
happening very quickly on deep chain
but you do not need to have machine
learning expertise
you do not need to get into the details
of how
the gpus work we've spent significant
amount of time
refining our structure which is powered
by nvidia gpus
and we're quite excited about presenting
and offering this product now
that makes it uh available and you can
basically go through all those
functionalities effectively
seamlessly which we believe is a big
deal i want to mention also that
this is not just simply an integration
of platform exercise
deep chain is backed by uh genuine
new ai research and uh innovation uh
we're actually very excited to present
uh basically the research we've just
done uh with uh and we're presenting
actually tomorrow at the neural nerips
uh
uh conference uh we are presenting this
work
in uh two workshops ml for molecules and
ml for structural biology as well as in
the covid 19 symposium
so this is not about the covid vaccine
it's about designing
in silico which means with computers
a therapeutic a potential cure using
reinforcement learning which is
you know this breakthrough decision
making ai technology
uh on which our company instead has a
lot of expertise
and so we're very excited about uh this
research work
that we are presenting in collaboration
with uh bioentech the biotech leader
that is
quite quite known and uh i wanted here
to uh
to say also that deep chain is trusted
by
industry leaders biontech as i just
mentioned
which has been recently in the news
thanks to their fantastic work
on the kovid vaccine with you know the
biotech physical
vaccine and also with nvidia
which is a leader when it comes to gpus
and infrastructure
so we are proud that instead deep to be
trusted by such
leaders in their fields and we look
forward to
continuing to build great collaborations
in the future so to quickly wrap up
before we
we take some questions uh for today i
just wanted to
present like how uh you know the
different options that are available for
for deep chain
uh as we said we have the playground
which is available uh for free in
limited format and again this
is uh you know sort of
or mentality at insta deep to make you
know those
ai breakthroughs available worldwide to
to students uh people interested in
learning more about biology and ai so
uh the playground is is going to be
available in a free version
with some limitations of course but it
will be free and
we have a pro version where you can uh
like explore much more thoroughly the
power of
those attention-based ai models in
biology
and this is a first and we're very
excited to bring this
product to market so at the moment we
are pricing it at 99
per user per month this is an early
birth pricing which is available until
uh end of january and so uh you know
this exciting point
to get started on on deep chain and
importantly as
as we mentioned we will be bringing in
also an enterprise and elite version and
in particular those will be featuring
the fully autonomous ai designer with
increasing levels of support
on terms of teams and the goal here is
to
really help professional users
uh effectively design the sequences they
want for
their particular uh tasks so this is
basically what we wanted to present to
you uh today
if you are interested in uh
bioinformatics
biology and ai uh feel free to contact
us
uh we are hiring uh insta deep the
company behind
uh deep chain has been recently named in
the 100
most promising ai startups in the world
and we're
very excited uh into by bringing like
uh like world-fast products such as deep
chain today
uh we hope you can try our product
get a sense of how it works and of
course we'll be very happy to
uh answer uh your questions uh both
today but also
in in the upcoming uh days so i'll stop
in here and
we're very happy to take some uh some
questions if we have some
from from the from the audience so don't
hesitate
so don't hesitate you can actually uh
type type in questions uh
directly and uh and also we are we are
also
reachable uh you know permanently uh we
have
if you actually create an account and
and go into
uh the the free version of of
of of deep chain you can actually get
access to the slack
channel and this is a great way to
interact
with our team so don't hesitate to uh
to give it a shot the team is available
and importantly you know this is really
a first step but we believe
uh you know there is a lot that those
you know ai powered approaches can bring
to biology
so stay tuned for our news obviously
today we are releasing
uh the playground but soon we will be
communicating about
the fully autonomous ai designer of
which
we presented you a sneak peek but we'll
get into a lot more detail
so don't hesitate to follow our news and
thanks again uh
for having uh connected today and we
look forward to hearing from you
soon and you can follow us on on twitter
as well uh the athens that dp i handle
is there so thanks a lot everybody and
we look forward to catching up with you
very soon